es ist bekannt dass der verdächtige
christian b ein grundstück in sachsen
anhalt in neuwegersleben hat auf diesem
grundstück gab es durchsuchungen und
dort sind unter anderem ein stick
gefunden wurden auf dem
kinderpornografisches material
sichergestellt wurde
das ist nicht der einzige verbindung man
hat herausgefunden dass bis jan b zum
zeitpunkt des verschwindens von inga
auch unmittelbar in der nähe war und ist
ein unfall dokumentiert worden er hat
auf der art bei einem parkplatzrempler
gehabt die örtliche und auch natürlich
neben dem tatort an dem an dem inga
verschwunden ist besonders aufwendig
deshalb haben auch die ermittler im fall
inga die ermittlungs führen
damals an der hand und kannst du uns
vielleicht für alle die den fall in gar
nicht mehr so ganz im kopf haben noch
mal ein paar fakten dazu sagen ich habe
es gerade schon angesprochen
seit fünf jahren fehlt von dem mädchen
jede spur was es noch zu dem fall enger
zu sagen egal ist am 2 mai 2015
verschwunden
damals konzentrierten sich die
ermittlungen vor allen dingen auf das
gebiet wilhelms hof wo das mädchen ist
man dachte wie man weiß dass sie einmal
kinder beim wald im wald war zum
holzsammeln und danach haben
hundertschaften immer wieder den ball
durchsucht weil man natürlich in erster
linie das hat dass sie dort verschwunden
ist sind auch in der nähe gibt es eine
land ein landeskrankenhaus strafe dafür
für psychisch auffällige straftäter die
sind damals auch damals schon christian
ii